Scot Solak former Patriots quarterback
and also radio host for 98.5 the Sports
Hub also the radio analyst for the
Patriots games joining us on the program
what do you make all this drama here
Scott with the ESPN article good morning
good morning talk about James Devlin and
his Pro Bowl the energize run game I'll
get to that Scott I'll get I'll carve
out five minutes on on Devlin's Pro Bowl
you know what it is man is it feels like
another another deep playoff run and a
Super Bowl run here I mean it feels like
I don't know the flake eight all over
again maybe a little bit of Spygate
thrown in there it just seems like
nothing nothing would better suit this
team that have some sort of outside
distraction to I don't know in a weird
way sort of motivate them to prove
people wrong do you think this is true I
think some of it's true okay what what
do you think what is the biggest thing
that you think is true I mean and I've
worked with Bill a long time and you
know things are done his way I think
he's setting boundaries was not having
Garoppolo in the building it's always
about the team you know and in the
article two they talk about you know
criticizing Brady after a throw in the
Texans divisional game which I totally
want our percent believed bills don't
son had from day one and I do not
believe that tom was upset about that
dead now of a sudden Tom has this frail
exterior to where he can't accept
criticism I think that comes with the
territory when he's dealt with Bill he
said nothing has changed since day one
from that standpoint I do believe they
they want they want to grow up a little
be the heir apparent that they offered
him extensions I don't believe they were
in the 17 to 18 million dollar range and
I say that because you look at Donnie
the the agent for both quarterbacks yeah
which I don't think there's a conflict
of interest because if there's a feel to
be made to where you could keep both I
think Don and this team would have
figured it out he said it's kind of
funny I really don't know what to say
yeah you know there's not really one
documented on the record source so don't
believe everything that you actually
read or hear so I do believe extensions
work
to keep Garoppolo here I don't think
they were in the 17 to 18 million dollar
a year right I think Jimmy would have
jumped on it but Scott why not keep him
for the rest of the season so you have
insurance for the playoffs that's what
you're trying to do you're trying to win
a Super Bowl here like why trade him and
wide trade him to San Francisco when you
know you could have gotten a better deal
with Cleveland that's what I didn't
understand and do you think Brady played
any role and getting Garoppolo out of
the building I do not I do not yes if
this was done i strictly think this is a
football decision and bill made the
decision to do it whether it was made
out of spite whether it was made out of
you know trying to sort of begin the
exit of certain people from here which I
don't believe I still think Bill
Belichick will be the head coach here I
think he was set to sent to San
Francisco for a second-round pick for a
reason to keep him out in the AFC
meeting I'm still invested here I don't
want to see the kid in the AFC and also
if I sent him to San Francisco guess
who's not going to San Francisco Josh
McDaniels you know his you know josh has
been here for a while now and he's had
chances to jump he could have went to
San Francisco a year ago and elected not
to pull his name out of it so I think
you need to look deeper into some things
as to where guys go and Bill's not going
to the Giants they hired a GM they
already hired a GM he's going to the
Giants he's running an old show what are
you gonna do now fire your GM and
guarantee that contract - it's not the
way the National Football League works
but hey this is what happens when you
win there's a lotta ego is a lot of
power I think they all get along and you
guys are a TV right pull up pull up a
picture from the Kentucky Derby last May
Brady took every quarterback with him
that's a select that's a select group
each and every year that he selects to
go with him to the Derby well I know
that Jimmy weren't such good friends
they wouldn't be he wouldn't everyone
his private flight gone down to the
Kentucky Derby with him I mean the other
things that Brady didn't help the
development of Jimmy Garoppolo that that
was brought up in the article
sure I wouldn't like quarterbacks
different you know I remember this when
I was at Maryland with new O'Donnell
we've never did one thing to help each
other because one guy plays
and it's it's it is the most territorial
position I think in in all sports I
really do more so than a starting
pitcher there's three of those guys
there's one starting quarterback in the
National Football League and if you
think they got the guy to replace you
and hey we all know it we all know he's
40 and that's all we talk about and
there's a young there's a young new
breed right there and he's gonna be the
guy to replace you I would do everything
I can to keep him away and not to
negatively affect him so don't get me
wrong they're not to hurt his
development but if I know a couple
secrets here and there I'm not gonna do
anything to help him to make him look
better to beat me out and we've seen
this before in fairness to this
situation with the Patriots it certainly
happened in Green Bay with Aaron Rodgers
Brett Favre a this has happened down
through history tommy maddox which John
Elway in Denver yeah we're talking to
Scott solak former Patriots quarterback
the radio analyst for the Patriots games
if I'm still fascinated with the
Garoppolo situation because it feels
like if I'm Belichick I know Jimmy
Garoppolo can take me five more years
seven more years maybe ten more years if
I want to do that Brady's not going to
be able to do that that's the
interesting part of this Scott it feels
like there was a power play and that all
of a sudden Garoppolo ends up in San
Francisco and you don't I don't care if
Garoppolo is with the Cleveland Browns I
care if I get a first and second-round
pick from the Cleveland Browns I
couldn't care less about that that he
could come back to haunt me that won't
happen anytime soon
don't forget he traded to blood so
within the division to the Buffalo Bills
he knew that drew couldn't beat him I
think and you watched Jimmy play and you
watch all this you've listened to all
the sound effects stuff he's he's almost
exactly the same as Brady you were
grooming him to be Biggs and Bill talked
about this last year at a press
conference he said when Tom's out and
he's not practicing it is seamless
seamless I mean I thought I'd almost
pulled my car over whatever pain hey my
dad coached Joe Montana and I've a
pretty decently close relationship with
Joe and I saw this at the end with him
in bbyong bbyong on San Francisco but
Joe was breaking down at that point
see that's the big difference here tom
has not really shown that you know I
don't have the filling in the armor I
could
to hid from the Giants or you know the
elbow surgery and all that stuff the
concussions the back injuries Tom hasn't
had any of that I mean he's had some
some issues with the Achilles this year
but honestly Dan I don't really know if
it is the Achilles is there a power
struggle I think there's a power
struggle with every great business
organization every everybody wants
credit for the success of it I mean last
time I checked here we are 13 and 3 I've
been doing this broadcast six years I've
called six straight AFC championship
games we do this one this year it'll be
seven in a row that's that's all you're
used to well who cares about the credit
these are the greatest coach to the
greatest quarterback haven't they gotten
enough credit yeah I think they have but
it's like you know what came first
chicken or the egg
look at your boy McLovin with his pole
there you know this is what people
outside here do I think it's something
for all of us to talk about we'll do it
for four hours today on the show but the
best thing about them is all three of
them all three players the owner the
head coach and the cornerback will
internalize this and nobody will address
this or talk about it who's more
important Brady you're Belichick like it
starts with Bill yeah I do who stays
longer see I thought this was Brady's
last year I really did and then might be
a Danny they went in for weeks maybe oh
you think it's a walk away if you win
scenario but see I just don't think so
because of Brady with this whole tv12
method and and and now you go out and
show everybody you put it into play it's
not you right yeah I mean but you you
you have the ability to readjust your
thoughts in your approach right if say
they go to Minnesota and they they win
this Super Bowl fifty two excuse me it's
two dynasties at the front end it's won
three out of four out of his first four
years in the league and it would be
three out of the final four years at the
end of his career and you bookend
no his tenure with two different
dynasties and I think that's one hell of
a way to walk out you know hey
why couldn't you have said that to him
to say hey look here's the deal Tom and
you know this day was gonna happen
we're gonna keep Garoppolo and this is
going to be your final year and let's go
out as a Super Bowl champ but our future
is him and you have to understand it the
way that you know Drew Bledsoe had to
understand this - when you came in and
this is how it happens
yeah but those are those are guys those
those are teams led by guys that you
know weren't going to the playoffs at
that time we're throwing 16
interceptions
he's gonna win the league MVP and we're
we're talking about potentially
replacing him this year or hurt this -
that there were some grumblings before
that deadline that people actually
thought bill would have dealt full time
prior to that yeah but you couldn't do
who's taking Brady at that age for how
long are you giving us yeah I know but
you even look at the start of the year
they weren't playing well at the
beginning of the year it was 2 & 2 in
September you lose Edelman you lose
Hightower and maybe this just wasn't
going to be their year so I can
understand what people would say boy
maybe get rid of the older guy and get
ready for the young guy this is gonna be
a lost year well I'm led to charge that
you know for the last six weeks maybe
eight weeks that Brady was your MVP it's
just that he had set the bar so high and
people were looking to give it to
somebody else in Carson Wentz if he
didn't get hurt maybe wins it but Brady
has been great but hasn't been very good
in the last couple of weeks but it
doesn't mean that the Patriots aren't
gonna win another Super Bowl they're
certainly favored have fun today I'm
sure that you'll be able to spend sorry
we didn't get in the Devlin Pro Bowl
maybe you spend some time on your show
doing that okay great I'll merica buddy
are you gonna be there even if the
Patriots aren't there no we go if they
win that's it okay that's it all right
well I'll be there no matter what
hopefully we'll cross pass hey Tomac
love it get up what's the best match
what's the best matchup for the Patriots
in a Super Bowl that should be his next
poll all right all right thank you Scott
that's consoling he's programming now
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 2/3
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]